what up beautiful bastards welcome to
another episode of HD podcast sound so
wrong it was like my dad said it hello
beautiful bastards here with philip
defranco made that intro in honor of him
this episode is sponsored by quick
stitch fix men man crates and Omaha
Steaks thank you to them more about that
later next week's guest is Vsauce please
leave questions for him on the subreddit
today's guest as I've already introduced
him but I wrote this out actually two
introductions okay good
Dan mentioned that to me he got the
mouse just want to make sure okay yeah
today's guest a man who needs no little
introduction hosted the philip defranco
show incidentally also his name yes
that's how original I am he's a news man
entertainer youtuber extraordinaire and
og youtuber in addition to be an
extraordinary I like I like that we
still use the term Oh G rather than just
like how is this guy still on this
[ __ ] site writes like five people I
still know from the beginning all right
okay I was like Smosh the GMM guys the
fine bro is very few right so when you
think G it's not an age thing it's just
uh how long you've been on them I mean
the age kinda just goes with it yeah I
mean when we started there was a guy by
the name of I think there were numbers
after but it was like geriatric that was
his name and he was like this old dude
that just shared life stories and he was
like the number one subscribed guy back
in the really before before was really
understood what that's not a YouTube
that I know no he had to be in his 80s
I'm probably uh I think that he did pass
away yeah because I mean this was I mean
we're talking about it we opened it you
laugh passing of a yeah how can he but I
love that it's a great guy told great
stories II died a little geriatric yeah
well he clearly had no illusions about
him and his name was loved it and I
loved it I think him being another one
person on the site at that time showed
really I think what we've all learned
like anyone can do it like that the bar
is very low obviously like the
equipment's getting better though
everything's becoming more professional
but mostly it ultimately comes down to
action stories things like that and that
was infant stage if you still think that
YouTube is that same way in what way
today like that anyone can pick up a
camera and make it on YouTube as far as
the quality yes I think I think that I
mean if you can grab a what's crazy is
you can grab phone from like three years
ago and have like decent enough quality
audio quality and throw it out there as
far as people finding it that's a hard
hard hustle that I don't even know how
you do but it's one of the reasons why
like we we don't do this in every every
single one but we have like a segment on
the show today and awesome we share
people shorts we share people's like
channels there may be under a hundred
thousand sometimes over where they where
they do stuff obviously we also keep the
trailers and stuff like that but yeah
it's hard like if I had to start today I
don't know how I would do it it's not
without a connection it's hard I mean it
was hard even when we started took us
like a year to get a thousand
subscribers but then but then you guys
would have like a breakout video and
then it kind of goes from there there
was you know yeah we had a few breakup
we had seven role breakouts okay that
would say like several big formative
moments in our growth I was one of the
biggest ones probably has to be the
vapenation video though that actually I
don't consider really one a formative
growth I think the first formula of
growth was we had IDI a takedown dispute
with fullscreen over a prank invasion
video that was the first time we were
like featured on reddit can I tell you
something yeah I contacted George I
think he's the reason why he reached out
to us maybe yeah because I was like you
I don't care if I remembered it on the
right side of this you can't [ __ ] do
this like it does like you can say like
we have the we have the moral no just
[ __ ] stop yeah so petty and
ridiculous yeah and I don't think it was
him I think it's just you just you see
just so well sorry what I mean is just I
don't think that it was personal I think
they had something on a piece of paper
yeah when when you end up in these
business meetings what happens a lot of
time and you use forget the people you
forget the community and you have to
always respect that first but yeah so
there was that but for me personally I
would say would be the vapenation videos
just because or a video because I'd
really only ever seen your responses to
something right like going after
something or like what someone did and
I was like oh this is awesome this is
like a whole different thing that I
didn't know it's gonna be but yeah just
in terms of channel growth vapenation
den result not my channel grow he knows
the most popular video oh well on our
channel it's a shame that it's the way
it is but on YouTube at least when we
were coming up was and it wasn't by
design it was just it happened
incidentally but the the dramas is what
you know like the the fullscreen one
people I think that was the first time
were introduced to this concept that MC
ins were were like had that power right
I think they were abusing it right and
so it became like bigger than than us
right the next one after that I think
there was the finebros yeah that was a
big one for us
there was the flow stuff we were when we
were beefing was so flow and they were
like threatening to sue us and [ __ ] I
remember like we what we were in New
York at the time I went to museum and
everyone there was like I like we got
recognized so many times it was the
first time that happened everyone was
mentioning those so forth yes right and
so then there was the csgo gambling one
and then the lawsuit one right so so I
think those were the big formative steps
but I mean there's there was channels
like leafyishere which and and channels
like him but have received like meteoric
growth mm-hmm and I'd are a few months
yeah it was just unbelievable and I
don't know that the algorithm would
would lend itself to that kind of growth
anymore unless you work or Logan Paul
because they did they did have meteoric
growth over this past year relies on
Koshi
yeah I was like I don't know if I should
say this but uh can we mention that we
have the same YouTube contact yeah yeah
yep you know that he also is the main
contact for logan paul go to me and then
are you dead like that has he made you
team a new tab i love to see graham
dabbing right on the haters you know
it's funny he has mentioned to me you
many times by interestingly Graham and
yes I am talking to you and I know you
know
you've never mentioned Logan Paul to me
I I got it out of him yesterday
he mentioned it and it completely
derailed our conversation I was like has
he given you that maverick merch no when
I've asked that I was like Logan Paul
Graham's a great guy
I appreciate it love you Graham I don't
and I'm like I certainly don't want to
take away the achievements of Logan jig
ball because I mean they're there on
that grind right but there's no
diversity anymore like a channel like
ours or even leafyishere which is like a
more extreme version right but I don't
see anything that's even a slightest
pitch a bit edgy even less edgy than
ours ever coming up in the atmosphere
the important thing I think to remember
is that everything's the biggest thing
when it is right and then that sounds
like heaven empty statement I remember
when phousi was like one of the biggest
things on the site and I think he and
several other people thought there was
nothing that could ever slow him down or
take him down and you just you just go
like where I go I've been here for 11
years I I've seen like huge jumps before
and eventually it stops yeah and so
that's why I think it's important for
people to plan or grow or at least try
mm-hmm and it's just yes you're right
you don't see that everyone but I will
say I mean the polls would you do that
like once again it's it's very easy to
talk [ __ ] but there's they've done a lot
of things it was very wrong some things
well you're right as far as growth
there's a diversity of content there
like the music videos thing whether you
think it's crazy or not but it's crazy
how much content they produce online of
use that they get is just unbelievable
whether you like it or not but it's
definitely the fad of the year was the
Disney bloggers and we'll probably have
a new fad and it's always hard because
you never know what's gonna happen I
don't I don't know I'm so interested to
see what's happening with with v2 or
anything I don't know any time there's
like more Asian I've heard like the vine
to stuff I haven't looked into it yeah
but because I never really embraced the
platform I was on it a little bit but I
don't know it just any anything new is
always exciting cuz it's just you're
gonna get these new faces who made v2
who's behind that is it Twitter's his
name it's the same guy that uh that just
made HQ trivia
and I remember I was that that crazy
mobile app that gets like 200,000 yeah I
mean what's crazy is like once they
start integrating integrating sponsors
and stuff it's couple of even more I
have not used it I've only ever seen you
talk about what is that what is so at
here's your free plug a it's a it's a
it's a daily trivia app right so I think
for us on the west coast it's noon and
six o'clock and they have a host there's
12 trivia questions you get three
options for each one and if you get to
the end you and whoever else survives
split the jackpot during the week they
get money yeah during the weekdays I
mean you have to win more than 20 to get
it so that's also kind of like the
little asterisk right because you have
hundreds of thousands of people
competing but near the end you usually
end up getting like 10 to 150 winners
and so I can split up but that's just
fun it's just like a nice little stupid
breakaway you know that reminds me of
xbox live back in the day we used to
have this crazy trigger yeah yeah then
everyone was bananas about remember it
back Batman this must have been like ten
years ago but it was pretty
revolutionary I guess they don't do it
anymore but shout out to everyone out
there who knows what I'm talking about
right let's move it on a little bit here
okay
congratulations on the baby boy baby boy
how is he he's good we were saying
before he's like a person now which is
awesome he's like the first three months
of baby is just like there I get I mean
I still with this one I didn't
experience it with the first one this
one I'm constantly getting spit on like
spit up on and it's just as a parent you
end up just like going
nothing disgusts me anymore yeah I can
just see anything and it's nothing
you're just immune like yeah shit's on
you you're like especially because he's
my baby so I'm just like whatever live
Evans but also like the same day that
happens you get different problems with
like I have a three and a half year old
as well he coughed directly into my
mouth last night I was reading him his
favorite monster truck and he goes daddy
I don't think it meant to do it on
purpose
what was your reaction just because it's
like you don't want to yell like just
just think about that someone this close
to you just does it give it
ha right in your mouth I'm gonna be sick
yeah but just I don't know it's it's
it's weird man it's like I got this
little purse in my house and I always
hate when I talk about my kids cuz it's
what every dad has said and it's like oh
here's the most unoriginal thing I love
them I didn't know I could experience it
all so here's the thing to anyone that
sees my children's like ah it'd be so
great it takes a huge amount of time a
huge amount of time if you want your
life to 100% be your life do not have
children I love the choice we made but
to done actually today I cancelled it
because I have no other opportunities
until like February I cancelled my
vasectomy for today so I could be on
this pot no don't say oh no no but now
but I mean just be careful oh my god I
have a third baby I'm just saying I
don't want to put too much on thanks for
sharing that yeah I was like when I say
- and done - and done I like there are
so many people like I mentioned it
offhand to this nurse I have to ever
hear I update my insurance and so I get
all this blood work and I mentioned and
she's like do it I had a I had I had a
whoopsie baby which I didn't know is a
term and her kids are 18 17 and 3 and I
was like yeah I'm not doing that cycle I
don't see Daisy but otherwise great
what's the procedure of a vasectomy are
you scared are you nervous about that
new child well I went in there and yeah
he's very handsy no I thought I didn't
think that the with what's the word the
check out before the the operation was
as handsy and pulley and and he's like
well essentially everything you felt
today it'd be similar it'll be like it's
a little bit different but you'll be
good we're just gonna know your child if
it's shown now when they show you about
the twisting and stuff like that and
sounds but you know what actually made
me okay with it and it's so stupid cuz
it's a YouTube video is I Wow
rhettandlink do it on their video and
they brought it sorry
huh what'd they get red link got a
vasectomy on anything yeah no it's on
their Channel
I mean talk about vlogging everything oh
yeah no no how do they show that well
they they have like this little I'm have
to ask about that they're coming on so
yeah oh yeah their children you know
they did it together like it was a they
hold hands
it was a burro I think so yeah I uh
that's strange
I'm a tree but I'm also a little bit
horrified yeah but I was like I
mentioned it in my buddy who films all
our vlog stuff he was like I can go
right I was like no I was like well
while they were filming they
accidentally went low there's just I
forget on which which guy but there is
now video footage in the world of just
dick and balls of one of those guys I'm
reading and that's that's that that's
next level trust that's an archive
somewhere yeah that's like that's like
December 1st 2007 be footage oh but what
do they mean it seemed okay okay I guess
they're doing a good thing
exactly so it's it's in and out there's
no recovery there's like a they say like
you can do light lifting and stuff like
that later
one of the other reasons other than the
podcast was we're going to Utah in like
three weeks and I was like I'm not gonna
be stuck inside while everyone's having
fun yeah that's it but I'm so I'm sorry
too bright to labor this cuz I'm just
generally intriguing like you know I
mean someday I'm gonna get my choked as
well like a tubes on your testes how
does that what what they they have like
this picture diagram thing it's
essentially oh yeah two cuts they cut
like tiny lettuce a little bit a tube
out of a they like got it and then then
and then I guess I just it wasn't either
throw is a backup but then they they say
don't have sex for like a certain amount
of time and you have to you have to just
go to town on yourself for a while
they say that yeah that's actually
terminology they use go to town on your
song yourself so it's like a so it's
like a pool and then you plug it up so
it's continually it just can't get
through there's like there's tension
there
well no cuz that I think you would
explode if there is actually let's noted
there this is the flow I think the way
they say it is it just thought I absorbs
it I think that's what at all yeah it's
very the body absorbs that's something I
should have probably researched it more
but I think that speaks to how much I
don't want to have a third child
okay I've heard a lot about male
contraceptives that are coming out like
men can take a pill and apparently be
really I mean it's something that's been
in development the thing is I wonder
like what it does to your system right
because I think what a lot of people
don't think of is like what like
everything that birth control does to
women like that sort of story about it
you're such like poisoning your body to
it which Thank You Lindsay for having
done that as long as good alright but
still yeah it's a they said now that it
may cause breast cancer oh my god it
increases but like it does increase the
chance for breast Grass Airport
apparently but it's like you know it was
like 14 out of 100,000 so I don't want
to like alarm people ok well that's yeah
they said 30 which sounded really scary
but then I don't know and it was yeah
was there like a 20 percent increase on
something that was barely 3 percent yes
I saw a headline that's the that's the
most dangerous thing in the world you're
like well I saw this headline okay well
what what I don't know I don't know any
of the facts but I believe everything
but and the thing is I don't do that on
my show I do that with conversations
with my wife constantly I hate doing
that that is like I shouldn't do this
this is this is everything I hate I know
that's this was not research okay
well it's on the radio talking about a
[ __ ] doctor I didn't go to just school
for eight years we called gynecology
I wanted to be called a doctor but uh
Greg you're not you're not a doctor you
just drove past the school but you know
my first my snap judgment when I first
heard about male contraceptives was like
oh my god like I don't want to put that
my body oh my god Ella's or women yes
are all taking that [ __ ] this whole time
for you guys and I'm and I'm just like
oh my god I'm also a very appreciative
that so much more than we do right I was
powerful presentation well you know it's
funny I understand Aborn baby yes I
understand maybe to one hundredth of the
degree cuz we just got a new puppy well
neither me and he left everybody can you
throw shredder on screen Dan can we go
damn the Shrek he's here with us in the
office now and I keep poops on us he's
on us he pukes and I'm like okay he's my
puppy I can deal with this but like I'm
sure the human I can't compare having a
puppy to a human child but like well I'm
they are needy I glad that I'm glad that
you at least press it with that because
there are a lot of people that do
one-to-one that person I'm like it's no
no it's it's nothing if you can let your
stupidest friend watch your dog it's not
the same thing
no I'm sure but it it's not even 100
I've done a lot of babysitting I okay so
I have some experience I was like I was
I was horrified of children though
before having hmm I like they just
creeped me out
but that's like that's like a deep I
felt like that ever since I was little
like if in my head like if you were
someone that like enjoyed spending time
with children or you were like happy to
be around children was like you're
[ __ ] weird you're weird oh why can I
be honest what I don't get it
you have to get it at all well yeah I
don't find them cute and and I'm and I'm
xima knife my own kids then I'll have a
different affection yeah but I don't get
it well I would say so the difference is
before before having kids I'd be like
okay I don't even want to be like if
there was just like the idea of a child
alone in an elevator around the only
person there [ __ ]
right right and I think there's the
comedian's of even have you been like
shot sketches are around that but like
now or even if they were like just
children I'm like I don't want to be
around there but now if my son's playing
with some I'm like high-fives and like a
good job and yeah I don't know it's I
wish I got it cuz I feel like a weird
like our friends no friends just it's so
normal I don't like I just and I know
that it's weird I'd want to have more
affection there's a lot of people and
like a sec dude I don't want to hold
your baby like that's too much well so
no one should be no one should be
pushing a baby that's all so much debate
okay but I just want no normal baby that
is completely normal
also I want to say since it's just while
we're on this topic if you are a new
father and you do not feel connected to
your child for like the first few months
or something like that it is completely
normal it is completely normal
the more parents I've talked to about it
the more I know I've learned that it's
it's a very common thing just for guys
to need that connection because the the
women gets to carry the baby in there
they're connected and when they feed the
baby it's more it's more of just like
this this thing this really beautiful
thing and then the dad you're kind of
just on sleep duty and night dry and
you're they're not giving back but once
they start giving back it's amazing but
but there are also father's that
immediately yeah but I I was interesting
I might have heard that but it makes
sense but there are a lot of desperate
guilty and I'm you know they're doing
the tip milk thing and spend a lot of
time with mommy
[ __ ] doctors in the know if you had a
little more oomph in your voice you'd be
like every every Italian friend my day
[Laughter]
and feel free to not answer this oh this
is something strange
have you tried breast milk no okay no I
feel like every new dad is like I feel
like it's a weird thing do I try the
breast milk maybe I knew that most new
dads have tried I think I think now
you're putting it in my head so I'm like
doctor you curious no okay I mean
I imagine it's not great really I think
babies are all pumped about it because I
love all they got no they love it
because it's great and God bless his
heart knew that when he made it I don't
have like a breast generally curious
I've never I don't really think about
breast milk usually I usually when
someone opens up a conversation with I
don't have a breast milk fetish right I
believe them thank you
guys let's take a quick break and we
will be back there's so much to talk
about guys you do not want to leave
don't go away
see you soon thank you to quip for
sponsoring this episode of the atrium
podcast let's be honest you're supposed
to brush your teeth for two minutes
twice a day but do you really you should
because who's I mean your mouths
probably disgusting in all honesty have
you ever put your nose in sides then
once someone's mouth and taking a deep
breath don't do it but with quip all the
sudden I'll stick my nose in there let
me tell you okay whether you answer yes
or no or maybe you need quit the
electric toothbrush that looks like it
was designed by Apple and cleans like a
premium electric brush but without the
high price ela what do you think over
there about quit Wow unbelievable and
it's electric - oh my god that vibration
is subtle but also powerful no guys
listen it's a new electric toothbrush
that packs just the right amount of
vibration as I was saying into an ultra
slim design with guiding pulses to
simply simplify better brushing at the
fraction of the cost of a bulkier brush
I am obsessed with my roll hygiene and
this is frankly the best toothbrush on
the market I endorse it personally at
the price point you can't beat it kids
get your loved one to put their nose in
your mouth today with quit so they've
been featured on GQ Oprah's o list mints
health and goop I know it's goop but it
sounds prestigious I'm I let me tell you
if I ever get the opportunity to be on
goop that's when I'll know I'll mate
I've made it it's a perfect time to give
quip as a holiday gift it's a gift that
they'll use everyday and it's not
something that would be just thrown in a
drawer it makes a boring part of your
day a thrill and I'm not kidding you try
brushing once with quip and you're like
I'm thrilled right now I'm a hundred
percent thrilled you don't have to go to
the store they they ship it directly to
your door and it's a perfect twenty five
dollar price point for these Secret
Santas you struggle with every year all
right you can even get quipped with
automatic brush head deliveries for a
year to keep the brush effective and the
mouth healthy until next holiday it's
literally the gift that keeps on giving
so it starts at 25 bucks so go to get
quick calm / h3 to get your first refill
pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
free at get quip calm / a suite that's
spelled GT q UI p.com
/ h3 thank you so much sponsoring our
show get quit get quipped with get quit
that's us that I just made that that's
you guys couldn't take me for that later
get clipped take you to our next sponsor
stitch fix if you're like a lot of guys
you could probably think of a million
things you'd rather be doing than
shopping for clothes oh I so relate to
in the parking and crowds at the mall
and the endless browsing and lack of
advice online it's enough to make you
want to rock the same t-shirt and dreams
forever but you can't because ladies
apparently care if you're wearing washed
laundry what apparently they care that
you have new shirts and stuff and then
you don't wear the same dish of old
outfit every day am i wrong and guess
the only ladies care about that
isn't that like that's like the
motivation right normal hydrogen I think
of guys if what if there was no dating
guys would like who what what are you
who are you putting the show on for it's
true Ethan will never do his laundry
until he runs out of anything through
where I don't understand the motivation
unless my basket is full and I'm
literally out of underwear why would I
ever wash it's just insane but that's
why you need to attract a female that is
gonna look out for your best interests
like I've done six nails and that's what
stitch fix is all about so let me tell
you about stitch fix they're reimagining
how to find and buy clothing you never
have to leave the house it's that easy
that easy
that is underlined and italicized
daddy's just go to stitch fix calm and
tell them your sizes your favorite types
of clothes and how much you want to
spend your personal stylist aka your
personal ELA in my case look some guys
are also great stylist yeah but they're
dying to [ __ ] they're all trying to [ __ ]
yeah like if there was no women it would
just be like all wrinkled and stinky
we'd be like you know a little shredder
yeah you no matter your personal stylist
aka ela someone like you look well then
get to work hand picking new clothes for
year based for you based on your style
in your budget five items are delivered
right to your door you try them on at
home and you only pay for what you keep
you try it on you see what you like but
doesn't fit you
it doesn't vibe the cuties aren't being
a track to do if it's not sending out
the pheromones it's in a bet so that
these are my friends shipping is free
both ways so anything you don't want you
just send it back and exchanges are
always free too you can get your fix
monthly quarterly or whenever you feel
like it there's no subscription required
it's easy the shipping is free why not
give them a try I promise you'll be
hooked get started now at stitch fix
dot-com / h3 and you get 25% off when
you keep all five items in your box
that's stitch fix comm / h3 to get
started today stitch fix
/ h3 my friends if you are in the market
for some slick new clothing or
toothbrush please consider supporting
our sponsors thank you so much let's get
back into it with Philip DeFranco
welcome back everybody the h3 podcast
with philip defranco the beautiful
bastard the easy there are times where I
don't know if I should change that I got
so many random comments like I want to
show you what like watch this with my
parents but they don't like the language
barrier I'm like but what about the
content show cuz it's not like it's just
all uphill from there okay it just sets
you up it's like this is this is this is
more and I'm not saying quality wise but
in the sense of rating this is more HBO
than PBS right I mean you don't curse
that much worse no it has to be like
impassioned I think that the difference
between me now and me several years ago
has just been my ability to mitigate
anger and not say everything that's on
my mind that's something I'm working
fire because you just realized like I
can't I can't go after everything yeah
right it's just you can't get anything
done you just end up in this like
horrible cycle yeah well let's talk
about before we get into some more
meteor topics I mean this is this is me
I just want to talk about him is I want
to talk about the fires going on here in
come on you were both out here it's
devastating I mean the footage I've seen
is really there's been over 400 homes
destroyed a lot of them in Ventura and
and the hills was at Bel Air I don't
know how many actually houses were lost
but everyone was the one that's closer
to like dice yeah okay I want to say
yeah so closer to us right
and I think my whole team was just like
are we in the event I was like no this
is the affected area yeah this is the
evacuation area but yeah the Ventura one
was crazy
so I'm from Ventura that's my hometown
and I mean I know the the city quite
well and just seeing the pictures and
knowing what was out there burning on5
name I don't think there's ever
experienced anything like that 400
destroyed and they were mostly there in
Ventura it was basically there was like
historic dryness and sustained crazy
winds from the Santa Ana Mountains just
resulted in a cataclysm of like there's
six major fires going at once yeah
basically people are describing as a war
zone
I've got a lot of media and pictures
that I think are fascinating and I'd
love to go over it with you guys things
Dan not missing a beat it's like what's
that we have a soundboard it's
excuse-excuse really only when I say
fascinating fascinating and now I feel
like I should come back so you got shame
yeah I did you let's do you let them
show you away from a word you use is
it's like everybody says fascinating
come on any tell people use the word
facias very useful word script I've
already been trained to like they'll get
you and you don't expect it but guys if
you have any questions or stories about
the California fire you'd like to share
with us give us a ring at eight one
eight two one four eight five zero four
we'll be taking calls in a little bit
wrote about that cool let me just let me
show you some of the [ __ ] I've been
seeing incredible stuff let me pull this
up here it's interesting I mean do you
feel like you're because you know like
you have experience there you were there
that this story it feels different than
when you see other horrible stories
because you have that just innate
connection Utley I mean I know I have an
emotional connection with like the place
and the people mhm and I like seeing a
video of the hillside on fire when you
know that geographical spot is
definitely hits home harder cuz I feel
like with my show that's the number one
thing that I try and get across is why
do you care about this because there's
so many horrible things that happen in
the world and it's just very easy to be
like that's just another thing there's
just other care then something like this
it's important I think to hold on to the
feeling right so that you know like
that's that's just even a part of what
everyone feels when any story right I
think that's important like that this
this [ __ ] was [ __ ] nuts this is a
airplane dousing this house in
basically extinguisher what they've got
here what they're dropping over the
fires is like this mix of water and like
mud and I guess they try to make the
water more heavy so it doesn't evaporate
okay immediately or roll downhill and so
they've got this red sludge they just
dumped over affected areas or in cases
houses to prevent them from burning
that's wild just oh my god this image of
this [ __ ] massive airplane just dump
it on this house it's crazy
it's been in LA mmm the poor
firefighters because they had like five
or six fires at the same time right I
remember that yeah and that dude I think
a lot of people saw this this is a 405
this is basically the most major
interchange in Los Angeles during
commute hours is probably like six am
sorry I just I had an inappropriate
laugh because have you seen the meme of
this well yeah wear it with a sign
instead of yeah saying where you're
trying offices uh welcome to 28 yeah I
would be it's unreal I don't know I
would be concerned it's like okay this
lava do you think the warrants do you
think they're slowing down so everyone
can take a picture or do you feel like
they're just they're worried because I
was I may die okay I'm sure they're all
worried but what can you do it this time
it's a freeway you got to keep going
straight
I mean I don't think that you can react
rationally in that cuz it's just you can
use it was such a bizarre yeah
do you like another one and the world is
on fire yeah I woke up and I immediately
opened Twitter news and that was the
first thing I saw in that way and I was
like what is going on outside I have to
check this is ten minutes away from our
house yeah well that's what live that's
why I freaked out when I saw it I was
like I know that yeah the Gettys again
we drive there all the time they're like
you or not yeah you're now entering hell
Jesus these were like the iconic shots
but I found some other ones that I
thought were great you know this guy you
guys probably met a lot of you may have
seen them but I thought this was really
full clip of humanity in action this is
some serious guy
he choose not to be interviewed because
when all the wilderness is burning
you've got Wildlife fleeing from the
scene where tons of wildlife being
displaced I mean here you can see this
rabbit has essentially flamed for its
life and the sweet [ __ ] guy pulls
over to save this little rhyme and the
midst of what can only be described as
an inferno I don't got anywhere needs to
be interviewed yeah you didn't want to
be on camera why just think it's like
because he's just like I just did the
good thing it turns out that he's
actually he just got I love one what do
you say I said it just turns out he a
does that he just has warrants that's
all yeah and then of course you get
stories like this here o Nevada I don't
know the way you view here this is a
west midland fire department seriously
unimpressed five of our firefighters
were tied up for an hour this afternoon
during a YouTube prankster whose head
had been cemented inside a microwave
oven look at this [ __ ] idiot how what
was he trying to keep in mind he's one
of us
yeah I I should have left him did you
see I'd sweep out my favorite headline
came from the next web and it says
youtuber tragically survives well done
what was he trying to do I think that's
his thing I I randomly I once again I
was like I was having a rush around
today but I looked through his channel I
think it's like he just does dumb [ __ ]
and that's the stink like he there's
something I think he said something no I
think it gets like a I might be wrong
I'm just that was just scrolling but I
think it gets like a million ish so I
don't know it's just whatever it's here
whatever problem everyone does
everyone's got their stick but I do hate
any time as you know that story let this
run and
this pepper your thoughts of what this
footage this idiot uh keeping
firefighters right keep that much like
the people saying people doing that I
had to [ __ ] deal with some idiot Dan
was telling me that apparently there's a
lot of people who are upset that the
firefighters were protecting houses in
bel-air and they're like oh it just goes
to show you that if you're rich the fire
department cares about you everyone will
find a reason to complain about
everything yeah I was I was in Texas for
I think it was like a movie festival and
I think one or two nights in someone
broke into my house my wife and I were
in there yeah
luckily the alarm went off the police
got there and there were people like
there are people in the comments section
of my my wife's video talking about this
saying the cops only showed up that fast
because yeah you guys are rich in weight
and I was like I mean that's that's not
a struggle right but the fact that there
are people out there that have that it's
just like god how would they know you're
white when your alarm goes off they got
a different they're like white people
alarm well we have a different 9-1-1
everyone knows yeah everyone knows it's
one-one-nine yeah no no no just like
that's where your head is not like you
could you could say like anything but
just that it's like I am so thankful
that they showed up in time because it's
like my wife and my son's life right and
they showed up fast they they were
badasses oh my god so thankful yeah
let's move on anyway I just thought I
thought that we should talk about it has
a fire effect to do it all gonna be both
yeah it just it freaked out the staff a
little they are probably not natives um
I'd have to I'd have to live a not used
to the state you know fire
no but also I mean think of like when
you think of SoCal you think of
earthquakes and there hasn't been like a
really big one here yeah in a while so I
think it's just maybe they're just not
there I don't know I mean we set up a we
had we prepped a go-bag we had we like
made sure our cars were full just in
case yeah you probably got that that
alert that was like no how old is it
because you guys got an Amber Alert and
you were like I don't need to be a part
of this no we were safely situated
between two and ferno's we got lucky
yeah that's good yeah yeah well we were
wearing Woodland Hills and so there was
like a fire in Ventura and there's a
fire in wherever the [ __ ] that is I
think they call it the Stovall fire yeah
yeah so we were like perfectly in the
middle of both of those right so see
you're good yeah weird weird we were
like oh man well were you chill or were
you actually trapped like we yeah we
didn't attempt to leave no I was staying
yeah I could feel in the air like oh
yeah
started to feel sick and then I go
obviously it's the fire it's the smoke
well you just yeah depending on like
which way it was coming cuz I would say
the first the first day of the event or
a fire I feel like around here we had
way more smoke than actually the
Skirball fire because I was going I
think West right but yeah I don't know I
mean it's there's what it is I uh I I
hate that it's affected so many people
I'm thankful that it didn't hit us I
mean this picture really floored me here
this is from Ventura this is this is the
effect bro this entire neighborhood this
is you man like in wilderness on a
hillside or anything this entire
neighborhood was leveled I got nothing I
just it's pretty incredible no one to
blame either no country's to bomb it's
just like damn we got [ __ ] up the act
of God is that harder you think when
there's no bad guy although I think some
people some people have made a bad guy
out of making it a like a global warming
our argument because I feel like yeah
that is interesting sorry sometimes
people just say stuff it makes me think
yeah it is in a weirder situation when
there's no like that guy yeah or them
you know it's just [ __ ] people [ __ ]
happens yeah apparently we've got a call
a fire call a fire call we've got a fire
you have been enacted
okay let's see here we've got a okay
we've got Kim Kim is on the line hey Kim
what's up hey how are you hi go ahead
and yourself
I'm doing great how did how are you
affected by the fire so I actually live
right at the Liberty fire in Marietta I
actually lived in the evacuation area
right next to it they had us evacuate us
I think last night they evacuated us to
our local park but thankfully like last
night they were allowing us to go back
home but today they set up an a location
for us to evacuate just if anything you
know happened but thankfully you know
they've taken how the fire is a control
like I think it's worth 60% Kinkaid
right but it was really like nerve
wrecking yesterday I mean the winds died
down last night I noticed like it was
pretty still out finally but were you
like in the in the evacuation zone was
it just you could see the flames
approaching you oh yeah almost
definitely it's like on a hill that's
across our home and it wasn't an unlike
a vegetated area an unincorporated
there's the word and it just it was a
bushfire and you can see it kind of
rolling over the hills and it was it was
very that's it that's I mean how far
away from it were you I mean it seems
like it was right in your backyard it
literally isn't right like if I know how
did you see it on the map but like
literally there's a park and a cook like
right behind that part in Marietta
there's like this big old hill and it
was right in front of our home and it
was the kind of direction you didn't
know it actually share homes or not
that's for me thankfully we're okay
yeah very glad very glad that you guys
are okay I saw pictures from some of my
dear friends their families who they're
still in Ventura and they took pictures
from where I grew up like a park and in
their front yard was just like
completely like just cast an orange glow
from and the fires just right in front
of them like place that I grew up is
just some really really wild stuff
yeah unfortunately like one one of our
like government
he worked in one of our schools she
locked her home but well you know we're
just doing our best to help out those
who have been affected had John I'm very
blessed that our home wasn't but you
just need to help out other people
mm-hmm cool well I'm glad you're okay
yeah and thanks for sharing your story
with us appreciate you stay safe thank
you thank you
take care shit's crazy I think that's
one of the important things though like
like something I mentioned earlier but
even then hearing just some persons ways
it's a real person yeah right that's
very easy to think like it's like okay
another thing happens let's do the text
donate or it doesn't matter like it's
real people yeah and it's like it's so
important to remember that yeah I think
that's really important I agree
sorry I got quiet I was just like that's
it's like breaking my heart yeah yeah
that was getting emotional when I was
looking at some of the the imagery and
stuff especially like some of my friends
or family in Ventura were just like it's
just oh [ __ ] happens dude it's weird we
forget you know you forget that [ __ ]
happens like in a big way well it's
stuff like that I think yeah it gets you
out of like the petty [ __ ] yeah I
remember I just I don't know I don't
know if we focus on the stupid petty
[ __ ] because we're trying not to think
like we're all gonna die one day like if
that's why we're just like and that made
me angry and I'm gonna measure of
ordinates do you think so I think so
it's a it's a it's a symptom of a life
of luxury lack of focus maybe like a
drive for something else well you're not
fearful for your life and your safety
like of like you know like a survival
mode worried about [ __ ] yeah exactly but
then think of how fast those of us who
aren't affected are gonna just be like
and then to today's different I don't
remember what I was think about
yesterday but in a way there's too much
[ __ ] happening in the world you can't
like internalize
there's too much information available
you can't feel bad for it because
there's too much awful [ __ ] happening
constantly everywhere mhm and maybe and
the world is in a better place and has
ever been but even still there's just so
much information I can't simultaneously
feel bad for LA it's just not healthy to
like carry around much grief with you
for like people in Syria people here in
Los Angeles who lost their house people
in Africa who are experiencing a famine
it's like you do you know text a couple
bucks and move on right and there is
yeah there is only so much time that's
that's one of the things that frustrates
me sometimes with the show that we make
because we'll cover something and
there's only so much time right so and
we kind of we have like a certain we try
to have a staple of domestic
international maybe something in turn a
tea and then people be like why didn't
you talk about this you don't care about
this and like but it is like there's
like ten horrible things happening I
don't have any given time and it's the
most important thing to ten different
groups of people so it's hard and I
think that way it sucks because you feel
like you're always letting down nine out
of ten people right so you just got to
just focus on the content yeah that's
well that's another topic always feeling
that's part of the pitfall of being
online person that you're always
disappointing someone and they're happy
to let you know it you can't like I was
saying before we started like I used to
use my social media as a way to just
[ __ ] about stuff and I ain't about
stuff and and now I'm just like how no
one wants to hear it from me like yeah
okay great yeah I got yes ten years ago
yeah I'm like oh yeah I'm a [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] yeah well let's let's switch
gears here a little bit since the last
time we had you on the show which was a
long time ago yes a lot has happened on
YouTube and in your career specifically
that led you to start your own patreon
yes DeFranco elite the Frank oh yeah I
checked it yesterday you're almost to
14,000 supporters which I think put you
either at one or two on the whole site I
think number two right now there's like
I drop off because patreon changed the
way that charging happens might just I
got off a scream phone call because all
the people that like all the creators on
the site didn't know until a day before
know what's changed so instead of
usually it's like five percent fee goes
to patreon you answer all the services
which is great and then they had it
listed I think it's like another five
percent but I guess it's somewhere
between five and ten I'm probably good
adding an additional it's transaction
fees so it's through a bunch of
different aggregates as far as how
you're paying but you're getting or that
whatever right so whatever number you
see I think then it's there's like a
percentage
yeah I'd have to double-check but they
changed it so now there's a 5% fee and
then the other percentage is paid by the
person that is is doing the purchase
right right so it's like 2.9 percent and
35 cents and so if you're giving a
dollar so those are the people that are
hit the most and and I think the
important thing is I think that's it's
going to affect these smaller creators
the most and that's I think why it's for
me also so infuriating because you could
have just asked people that use the site
if or make it and so I'd like I had a
conversation with them after the fact it
was an off-the-record conversation so I
can't say like the specifics yeah but I
think you have to make it optional
it's obviously I don't look it I don't
look at patreon as a donation I see it
as a transaction right it's not like a
GoFundMe people support at different
years because you get early videos you
get exclusive videos exclusive live
streams we used to sell signed posters
with my own merch company that I
launched forever ago all we did was we
kind of migrated that over so it's like
you can just do that there you have
exclusive mug you know stuff like that
so people can get their awesome [ __ ]
support the show and and move forward
but there are people that use it almost
in a donation sort of way um and and
those are the people I think they're
gonna get hit the most because those
guys they accept $1 right because we use
it ours as a service we have our first
tier at $5 like what we did is kind of
based off of roosterteeth first they
have like a $5 and I think at 35 then
maybe it's 15 so we do 5 10 35 and yeah
and it just I don't know it really is
conversation the main thing is
conversation because and sorry I've like
feeling how I was feeling when I was
screaming it's a platform like I love
patreon right rather than having to when
when we did our jump rather than having
to create an own owned-and-operated
thing there's just a built in thing that
we could start it on I still plan on
migrating it to an owned and operated
because I see it as a service but they
constantly talk about there
acet are its creators then why didn't
you [ __ ] talk to us why on such a
massive change that affects everyone
like it's it's great to everyone for to
[ __ ] talk YouTube but but when you're
when you're the counterculture you're
the answer to the problem right and I
mean this whether it be indie media
whether it be this you can't then do the
same [ __ ] or at least call yourself on
it I do think that they are calling
themselves on it but it's just just talk
just talk most most everything online I
think you probably feel the same as far
as communication it comes down to
communication it's so frustrating yeah
that's as well so you're saying that if
you like if you donate a dollar
you're gonna lose like 10% of it as
opposed like if you donate five it's
gonna be well I think I think the big
thing is also to take away the word
donate right I personally do not see
patreon as GoFundMe as a donation
service there are some people that once
again that use it but I think that when
you have someone that's paying a dollar
for whatever it is so like the cosplay
cosplayer do you like special shoots and
dave rubin does exclusive live streams
and stuff like that i think but yeah
you're going to the people are going to
be affected the most are the $1 to the
people that it may be to them the $1
seems like a donation rather than a
purchase mm-hmm yeah right
well I wanted to ask you basically that
since you've switched to to patreon yes
or I guess started it how has that
direct support changed your operation
because I know for yeah you were owned
and operated by discover or discovery
what was it so it was discovery and then
and then well it was I was originally uh
I think we did deal with the revision3
then we were discovery digital network
property then we were group 9 right so
there is a lot of exchange of Gahan's a
lot of different people I can only talk
so much about that legally okay what
questions you have because I can answer
some well okay I just want to know
basically how has it changed now that
you know you're owned by yourself right
you yes you own it yes you presumably
you bought the rights
yes to it for yourself right and now
you're your fans or
patrons or whatever you want to call it
subscribers yeah are the ones that are
funding your show mm-hmm so how so how
is the experience different well one I
would say it's amazing there is no day
that we walk in going today we could
just lose money because we're gonna make
a Philip DeFranco show we have when I
when I first when I first bought the the
rights back bought the channel back we
had six employees as we're kind of
branching out and building out
we have 16 employees right and so the
whole it's kind of that huh 16 that's so
yeah that's surprising they so many well
so yeah because right now we only have
the two channels and so it kind of goes
around the same build out of when I
first launched on if you guys are
familiar with SourceFed yes so early on
the whole point or the whole way that I
kind of try and grow a business is we
grow fat so that we can split off and
then be operate lean so grow fat operate
lean and it's incredibly important so
that's what we did before launching
SourceFed before we launch SourceFed
nerd the reason we had six hosts and a
[ __ ] ton of editors on SourceFed was so
that we could then split off into
SourceFed nerd right operates clean lean
and also there's a lot of training we
brought on researchers to help with the
show but also a lot of the new content
and there was there's a lot of having to
work with these guys so that like we
start with four we have three there were
several times during the process of
trying to train these guys that we
almost threw out like career-ending
false information that I had to like
catch at the last second but the three
that I have now are [ __ ] awesome like
I trust I oh I don't wanna say blind
trust because that's that's when you get
into a scary place but that's like my
new core so now in the next jump as we
start creating these these new shows
need more researchers need more people
to investigate into situations I have my
core and I don't have to train them
myself right so build out their PA is
for first set building it's kind of low
cost low low ish need because we're
still just testing sets testing angles
building things out while I'm doing the
show new editor
someone to handle patreon fulfillment so
making sure people get their poster is
when something gets lost in the mail or
broke and all he also has to do is send
a message they contact Hillary she's
badass she handles it
and yeah and so right now we're still in
the buildup we keep everyone that's on
to Frank Willie we have these and a
month town halls and we're like these
are new hires these who are looking for
these are the shows we're working on
we've tested a one show that we were
feeling pretty comfortable with it's not
a good show what was it it was called it
was supposed to be our like non newsy
show or like yes sure that can be like
personality based we're not gonna run
with it it was called yuck City we
probably move forward with getting
graphic packages and do it or doing
everything too soon but like our big
thing is first beginning of next year I
want to say semi daily I'm scared to
promise daily live shows going back to
pilot shows yeah
so having so once again this is if
you're coming from DeFranco elite this
is not news to you for general public I
want to have a mishmash of the podcasts
that if you if you ever saw the podcast
I did with Casey nice day right I want I
want to maximise on that model because I
love this right it's just like when
we're across from someone you're not
doing like that side fake or someone's
across the room it feels like a real
conversation yeah so I want to mix that
with involving the audience a lot more
yesterday I tweeted out it took an early
version of an app that we've we've had
that we're going to release soon that
kind of brings back on a base level you
could say just as video responses but
what we see it as is just this this big
jump in to having that direct video
video video to video connection with our
audience right
you can still comment text and stuff
like that but the focus is video what is
video 2 video mean oh so I mean I just
mean like I'll whip it out whip it out
but I pan out for you it's called the
philip defranco a but it's not going to
be called that so it's just a really
basic thing of so I'll have a video
right there and that's essentially going
to be sorry if you can't see that camera
it's essentially going to be like oh
sorry like Dan's like hey can you a
[ __ ] idiot so essentially once again
very very basic thing we try and make
things is or everything involved with
what we're doing very simple so all this
is is just this will probably be
initially for what's your opinion on
this right i talked about i talked
yesterday about a story with august ames
taking her life right and there are a
lot of people hearing stories of people
they personally lost right and there's
there's only some there's only so
connected you can feel to text right and
i want people to have like a
conversation i even i suspended the
friday show as it was being done because
it essentially just me replying to
comments and i wanted something that was
more right and I've said it for several
years like I understand that it was only
serving a small portion of the audience
but I loved video responses I felt so
individual video responses to comments
yeah so essentially what'll happen is
these are some videos I made last night
or not but that one is but there'll be
video and I'll say like what's your
opinion what's what's a story you have
around this if it's if it's a story in
the news what's your insight anything
like that
and then people can just easily submit
interesting and the most important thing
is it's easy for us to extract right now
you can do it on Twitter but it's semi
public you can do it on Instagram and
snapchat but you're stuck in vertical or
there limitations so we wanted to have
this whole ecosystem where we built this
out and then people once again when I
say video to video it's not just people
sending video responses there can then
be sub thread x' or have people talking
to one another
um yeah this is something you're working
on yeah I have my other question I'm in
my follow-up and that you've touched on
a bit was me you what are your plans for
the news organization that you're
starting and and what are the plan or do
you have plans to expand beyond the
philip defranco show yes
no of course the biggest thing the best
success I've had so far is hiring
researchers and organizing some of some
of the new things we're gonna launch
where we've had the biggest problem was
right before my baby was born my plan
was get researchers get a CEO right
someone that's running my business for
the five to six hours that I'm in that
room it's incredibly I love doing my
show it's I I would but it's very hard
to grow past that when that is seventy
percent of your day sure we had someone
lined up for reasons I won't go into
after lots and lots of
negotiation and and and and kind of
going through the process it fell
through and that really I mean it's not
the one thing that [ __ ] my timeline
really because if it's hard to find good
people I mean meaning well know that now
the big thing for me it's trust the last
time but someone in a position of power
it was [ __ ] no good it was my like
the worst thing I've ever done many talk
about it and that sounds interesting
that person was on a specific list their
other know [ __ ] but so but luckily I
have like a fantastic executive producer
and Amanda morones I think you might
have also met her she's a [ __ ] Banff I
like the show as is what he is struggle
if she wasn't in the company but she's
been handling like [ __ ] six jobs
along with me
but we've been still growing still get
the also the other hard thing is finding
people for camera in LA its we've found
either people are immensely too far too
liberal and that can be offset if I can
find someone very very conservative but
it is very hard because it's very easy
to find an entertainer that can make
news consumable that's what I did with
SourceFed right you have to go through a
[ __ ] ton of people you find people that
are genuinely talented that's great
but when it comes to what we're doing
there has to be a respect there some of
the respect can be kind of hands it off
from me to whoever this person is right
this is me vouching for someone the one
I have to find someone that I can
actually vouch for and someone that's
reliable and someone that it wants they
want this to be their their main thing
and not a thing that just promotes to
their thing right I need like partners
right now we're going through the
process but those are I think those are
the biggest hurdles you look you're
you're tasked with finding on-screen
talent that can hold their own show
under your umbrella yeah I could like a
anchor like one of these political shows
you see on television yeah and cuz my
big thing is I want this to be someone's
main thing I want to be supportive of
them and make sure they're good and I
don't want to lock them down and some
contract that makes things weird right
what happened that's when my father
passed away my father's actually left on
freaka save that for something more
tragic Papa saw with that I don't know
if that was intentional but it's
certainly interesting huh yeah [ __ ]
sorry but once again this is all stuff
that we shared our town halls we try not
to talk about stuff that's that's -
that's right
I'm trying to put this in a restaurant I
think he said that it wasn't anyway we
just lost 3,000 [ __ ] viewers and shut
the [ __ ] up about this spam this
soundboard no that's not what happened
pretty interesting production style and
right when they get to a point just
[ __ ] shock everybody yeah just throw
it out there all right listen
let's take our break we've got a lot of
stuff still left to talk about my
goodness I have one one I'm gonna see I
never actually questioned about patreon
I wanna yes how do you see patreon
fitting into your long-term goals do you
see it winding down as the business
becomes self-sufficient or is it like an
integral part of your business model
going forward how do you see the future
of it is my plan is to move it over to
an owned and operated site but because
the problem is I think far too many
people view patreon as a donation
service they may have made they have
made changes internally and with how
they market their company so that they
can get away from it but but that is for
people that need patreon out there every
day they don't look at it like they
still see it as like a donation service
so once again the way that we view
ourselves is it's transaction you're
getting all this stuff obviously it's
it's fan funding in the sense of the
same way like when you sell a shirt when
you sell merch because all that money is
going right back into trying to create
more and more content right when someone
buys a shirt they're not buying the sure
because it's just like pretty cool right
they're wanting to buy it because it's
supporting you right because their heart
is something but my thing especially
after what happened today my plan was to
move off in two to three years I think
that unless something else changes or
there's a communication issue I do not
want to be liable for other people's
choices right the whole point of
everything that we've done is so that
I'm a master of my own future here right
and so when someone just [ __ ] changes
everything like your core the thing that
has made you bulletproof I got we had to
deal with we still deal with it like D
monetization issues today the people
that that are on that are on DeFranco
elite that's that get the get the stuff
they're supporting us that way they make
my show bulletproof I don't have to
worry about t monetization I don't have
to worry about we're seeing more and
more of these [ __ ] crowds of people
that don't like what you say and they
find some [ __ ] you said like 20 years
ago out of context and then they try and
make you lose your job lose your sponsor
I don't have to worry about that because
I have an audience that supports what
we're doing there they're here for what
I'm doing and here for what we're
building right and that's yeah I mean
it's it's fantastic as far as it winding
down we knew that in the first year that
there would be initial drop-off there
are people that just support want to be
there and then they'd leave our art but
our long-term thing is releasing content
early some exclusive stuff but it's
mainly a focus on the early content
because we want them especially with
what we talked about we want to make
sure that that gets out there because
we're always trying to have a
conversation about news and pop culture
because I think it's important to have a
an actual dialogue and not just scream
at each other when you can sometimes
sometimes you still do right okay I mean
that I like the idea of I think that
would be useful the separation of being
like hey there's a subscription service
right
and because patreon just definitely does
hold the connotation of being like a
donation site yeah I mean when we were
using it a long time ago I had that
attitude of like I at one point I just
removed the rewards altogether because
all were like I was like look we're
because we were doing so much work that
we could like that became that would
have been our main job just fulfilled
sending stuff to people totally well at
the time you it was like
I was actually and making stuff yeah
that was I was just like listen just you
know help us out if you want that was a
while ago but like I think that that
would be I think interesting for their
future and I think that's why they've
they've started making references to
your business your shows things like
that I think that they are understanding
because it's it's it's a massive tool
for me but I also think that it's
something that we can do on our own own
own enraha operated site and I think
that's the plan is to start slowly
moving you know okay alright let's take
a quick break guys we will be right back
with philip defranco thank you to our
sponsor man creats it's really hard to
pick out the perfect gift but all too
easy to totally flub it up you all know
what I'm talking about introducing man
creates dot-com the surest way to find
gifts that guys will actually love
guaranteed these guys sent me a whiskey
appreciation crate mm-hm and it was like
it's really it's an unique and
incredible experience they said it in a
crate and they make you pry it open with
a crowbar my testosterone levels were
peaking I was fully torqued my hair was
like frickin growing out my face dude it
was crazy bro I mean I didn't mean this
in a good way I know that it was not
that hard to open it well it's or anyone
was kind of worried right it's a it's a
fun level of challenge yeah I was
slightly worried that I was gonna like
no I'm not like the manliest guy it was
just fun it was like it was fun bro I've
been like fully erect since then though
seriously that's like the manliest thing
I've done in my whole life listen they
send you great gifts with hundreds of
options in crates it's a total blast
this isn't a cheese of the Month Club or
a new tie okay man creates offers over
100 hand curated gift collections for
every type of guy from the rugged
outdoorsman to the sports fanatic and
everything in between
that's right everything they actually
have incredible amount of options I was
I was blown away by the diversity
they're like the whiskey appreciation
crate with
personalized decanter in glasses for his
favorite drink that's the one I got it's
got my name on it
I got huge it's guys it's great or the
grillmaster crate with a brass knuckle
meat tenderizer in a cast-iron smoker
box beat your meat literally just go to
man crates calm pick the perfect crate
and choose the delivery date did that
rhyme I feel like that was like go to
man crates Cobb pick the perfect crate
and choose the delivery date single Oh
poetry when his crate arrives he gets to
pry that bad boy open with his own laser
engraved crowbar both men's health and
Allure magazine are saying man crates
are the perfect gift for men and those
two don't agree on anything
everyone knows that like the Capulets
and Montague's oh I wonder what goop has
to say baby they have thousands of
five-star reviews on every man create
comes with a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee own the holidays
with man crates it's a lot of fun
honestly I think any guy receiving this
would have a total blast so go to man
crates dot-com slash h3 and get five
percent off your order guys that is five
percent off at man crates with an S at
the end man crates dot-com / h3 man
crates with an S at the end com / h3
they give your support and finally talk
about beating your meat I'm ready to get
meat the meat man Omaha steak our next
sponsor oh I'm a meat man that is in
love steaks and he's really good at
cooking them oh thank you
listen guys Omaha Steaks is giving an
insane deal to our fans right now and in
spirit of the holidays for $4.99 you can
get the family getting nine $49.99 fifty
dollars essentially - one cent if you do
the arithmetic you can get my family
gift pack when you go to Omaha Steaks
and what you have to do is go to the
website Omaha Steaks
and search the code h3 so go to the
search bar enter h3 and you're gonna get
75% off this bad boy here $200 when sold
separately together $49.99
this pack offers all mistakes is a
unique gift for gourmet food lovers they
got over 500 gourmet gift ideas great
steak experiences the most flavorful
aged tender beef seafood poultry pork
veal lamb my god
the there's just it's a mayhem man
there's just animals of every type
getting packaged up out there but I love
it because I eat it they also have
veggies desserts appetizers pasta soup
seasoning sauces and so much more that's
everything lenient quick shopping age 21
days to unlock the full flavors of the
cuts my friends hand trimmed
vacuum-sealed online recipes wine
pairings and more let me tell you what's
in that family was it got the family
gift pack
this is gonna blow your mind for $49.99
two fillets two filet mignons two top
sirloins two boneless pork chops for
born boneless chicken breasts for
Calabasas I love saying kielbasa I'm
happy that they brought down its of
Calabasas for Calabasas sausages for
burgers for potato au gratin that's a
little too classy for me to say properly
it's potato scallopini I don't know
what's fancier algorithm whatever
accurate tune for camel cared-for
caramel apple tartlets one Omaha steak
seasoning package plus my friends in
honor of me saying kielbasa and having
so much fun they're adding an additional
four Calabasas sausages free
it's a calabasa party go to a mistakes
calm and enter the code h3 into the
search bar and get 75% off it's the gift
guaranteed to be a hit my friends I want
pack for everyone in my life and me
myself too I got get those cab asses so
my friends if you're in the market for
some meat or some sauces I know crates
oh if you're in the market for a great
gift for a guy or some meats consider
supporting our sponsors ups for the show
guys thank you so much let's get in
right back into the beautiful bastards
with Philip DeFranco welcome back to
extra podcast with philip defranco I got
one more follow-up question about the
patreon yes there is there's a lot of
people who I guess criticized people who
have patreon so I guess there's a
distinction like you said about a
donation versus subscription model or
something right and I think that there
are people on the site that do it in
that way I think even you guys were
referencing that you would when you had
one you used it in that way definitely
and I think that they exist in in both
places and you can usually tell the
difference based on are you getting
something or are you not getting
something right and I mean in a per
month right content things my merch
business is integrated into what we do
there oh yeah wait sorry I cut you a
question on well so the the point I'm
getting at is that a lot of the
criticism that people levy against some
people on patreon something that you do
- yes is that they hide the amount of
money they get they only show that
number of great reasons they have and so
my question is what what is your reason
oh yeah what is your reasoning for
hiding the dollar amount well I would
say one we choose just to not show it I
think when you start a conversation with
hide it automatically seems like sorry
something various I guess is happening
you sure no I think it's it's 100 it is
a valid question I am glad that is
coming from someone that has not been
salivating to try and destroy my career
in one way or another for years so I I
don't show it because we don't see it
once again as donations if it was a
donation cyant like when there was the
the legal fund right of course show it
but I see what we're doing
once again as very close to roosterteeth
first we're in like the infancy of it
more and more of the content is being
made content stuff
access all that is there's a one-to-one
transaction so in one way it's the same
reason why in any other small business
that has a subscription service like
that wouldn't say this is how much money
we're making every individual month that
you're going to dissect and then start
trying to make one-to-one comparisons
the second is while I think that a lot
of my audience understands business like
we we go kind of our demo is very much
like people that are entrepreneurs and
trying to to move forward whether
they're in the infancy of that or they
are there are enough people that do not
understand everything that goes into
building a business not just operating
but growing that I think it would be too
damaging people not taking into account
that all that money
it's obviously taxable all of that money
I am pay salaries on top of that
benefits I have to not only have
insurance on all our gear but if I I
have I have a plan in case someone
doesn't like some should I said about
them and they're gonna try and Sue me
into silence like yeah well I have to
search for that yeah I had I had a
conversation today they're like you're
covering you're covered on everything
and then in addition we have an umbrella
package right right didn't sued before
really we can't get umbrella packages
that was what we were trying to get
there's like a live yeah I guess
lawsuits right like copyright get it Wow
so so there's all that then there's rent
utilities there's probably stuff I'm not
even thinking of right now and the only
thing that I would I feel then
comfortable and sharing and and I think
it's the reason why it's it's so
frustrating to me it's like I'm paying
myself less money than I made last year
I'm paying myself seven figures less
than what I could have signed a deal for
if I just want to make money if I if I
wanted because once again everyone's
trying to or not everyone the people
that are trying to go after me and most
of them are doing it with really bad
information I don't know if they're
peddling [ __ ] or they know that they
are lying I do not want to just assume
someone's lying to kind of try and go
for my throat but like I wait I lost my
track I lost my track you where was I
were talking about operational cost
right ball peddling [ __ ] right so
and then people try and money the
and they'll say like Philip DeFranco
he's worth 20 million dollars and then
in the same thing they'll say like 8
million and like that's a [ __ ] range
both of those are wrong by the way
yeah and the no reference Philip
DeFranco he was a founder of maker
studios that dudes [ __ ] loaded what
about the part that it's public
information if you just do a [ __ ]
little bit of research I got a [ __ ]
nothing I got nothing from that sale
right and that's it's a big no I think
it feeds into things like for me it's
it's not about the money like for me
making money that it's like there are so
many different avenues I could cut from
a why am i growing a 16 person staff
when I had six when I could just cut
down to two and just do the philip
defranco show cut everything else out
and make more money it just doesn't make
sense and it's just it's just generally
frustrating I just I don't know I just
have in my head of what else I wanted to
say I try not to engage when anyone
tries to fling [ __ ] at me because if you
engage once they they expect you to
engage on everything and then if you
don't they're like well that's a tell
that's like no I just want to deal with
the obviously incorrect [ __ ] like
the people [ __ ] the people going at
me they're the same people that could
[ __ ] use some extra money for maybe a
proper research team when the person
involved is someone that's [ __ ]
falsely accusing someone of being a
pedophile and then oh it's okay though
they apologized afterwards or when it's
the same person that's [ __ ] I don't
want to use his name because he feeds
off of it but the same person that when
I was talking about the daddy a 5-story
threatened threatened to say that I was
abusing my child
he has deleted that video he said if
that kid if the kids from the daddy of
five family get taken away I'm gonna I'm
gonna call child I'm gonna say child
abuse with you and I'm like you're
you're [ __ ] you're gonna make a fold
false child abuse claim you [ __ ] like
that's the kind of person that goes
after you and I try not to engage I try
and do nothing and it's so frustrating
to see someone that's AAB it just it's
Donna it's disgusting
it's disgusting it's always really
frustrating to see wrong information
about yourself out there in general
we've seen it
myself not even related to who is saying
what just it's so frustrating to not
wait this is wrong but when you get to
CERN I want to say there is there's a
picture that says and it's such a genius
move well it's either genius or
incredibly stupid there is a picture
that they don't do any research into all
the stuff we've built out which we've
been very public about if you watch like
a vlog or tweets or [ __ ] anything
they're like he eats the most he gets or
the most he's done with his patreon is
he changed his pillows right and then
they say and that's what he gets for
250,000 dollars a month on patreon which
I will say is an absurd and ridiculous
number now it's it's idiotic if they
actually think I make that or it's
genius because they they're throwing out
such a [ __ ] number that they're like
well then what is it and then I still
stand by the same reasons of why we
don't choose to share that number
especially with I mean once again we
were talking about it I do plan to move
it off because I understand why there is
a connotation with patreon and and
donations mm-hmm and that's in no way
what we see ourselves as and in no way
what we're doing it's fan funding in the
sense of selling a shirt giving a
product giving videos et cetera
yeah I felt good I mean I think the
analogy that you made about other
subscription services not because it's a
business it's the backbone of your
business yeah and I mean if the people
who subscribe to your patreon are
satisfied right and that's and that was
one of the things too it's like one
person didn't get their poster and
they're like philip defranco scamming
his fans they're paying for posters and
i'm like one person have you ever favor
mashup to product [ __ ] breaks [ __ ] gets
lost that's why we have a person that's
dedicated to make sure you get your [ __ ]
like that's why that person gets paid
make sure you use that person I guess
there's a natural segue here to my next
point dogs yeah
all the sound board buttons together
whoa we got a wu-tang in a bucket over
that come that was kind of cool I've
never felt whiter
yeah the patreon thing is really it's
it's tough because like I think that the
separation of it of it I think the point
that you make is the most important of
separating it out from subscription to
straight-up donation right right like
our season we closed our so long ago
because we're like look we don't we
recognize that taking your money at this
point is disingenuous because we're
self-sufficient now and at the time we
use it we really needed the money right
it was really helpful but that was a
different case right
that was before Adsense made any money
for us or before we had any sponsors so
it was really just a donation based yeah
yeah but what you're describing is
actually different yeah it's really I've
always been torn on the whole patient
thing and that's a thing like I can't
get angry at people that are being fed
information that's wrong or they just
have like that connotation in their head
of okay that's the connotation but the
thing that's frustrating is the people
that then lean into [ __ ] even though
the actual information if you just do
your work especially juicy stories all
like all the pieces like all the the
attempts to hit me all it did was make
me feel such an appreciation for idubbbz
like when when he goes after you he hits
you clean and you just have to watch
what he gonna be like well [ __ ] me but
but then and then you watch other people
you're like oh [ __ ] this is this is some
bush league did you need the Adsense
also wait I want to point something out
right because I'm I'm so ridiculous I
screenshot this because it was so
priceless the guy one of the guy I don't
want to mention his name that that went
after me for having a patreon which
gives us stability gives us safety is
helping us grow I think within 24 hours
of that same video he tweeted had enough
of YouTube D monetize my videos so I
appealed and it gets monetized I wake up
again and it's demonetised again
overnight my views have been cut in half
and my videos have been getting D
monetize like crazy so demotivated right
[ __ ] you
you well yeah I mean they're like
okay even let's say I agree oven so sad
if my clothes after that was me cracked
my fan let's say like I'm gonna plate
I'm gonna look at this from all you know
it's like actively like but I have some
issues with patreon mmm I have some
reservations about it but even if I say
I feel uncomfortable with the idea of
patreon you go there you can only scan
people on patreon to an extent like
people are know what they're getting
themselves into right they know what
they're giving money for right and
they're free to stop anytime it's not
like um you you you you can't really by
the very nature of it you can't really I
mean nobody's giving money against their
will and and the whole thing itself is
pretty upfront like yeah whole system of
it the also a if the only way you could
be scammed is in two ways one i'm just
pocketing the money on making bank and
just keep in mind wait I said this
somewhere else not to you I'm paying
myself last oh no I already said it yeah
yeah okay I lost it sorry guys um I
there's - wait there's two ways Oh scam
of it right so it's you charged for
something and then you don't send it out
to them right so like a poster which
once again if anyone's ever supported us
you didn't get your tip contact us there
is an easy way to get it and the people
that don't get it are incredibly in the
minority
the second is growth right we said that
we want to get more videos get more at
everything out but even in the launch
video I say I don't want to blow smoke
up your ass you're not gonna support
this and then instantly this news
network exists it's going to take time
and I'm not saying that just because I
want to take my time because I know
having built a business before there are
pitfalls there there are things we're
just like [ __ ] we can't move on this
this is hard especially in a business
that I I personally I care about trust
so much with everyone that we bring on
because I've had so many well not so
many some specific horrible instances in
the past that I never want to experience
again
so yeah just stuff like that it's just
but III think but what other point what
other problems because I love I wanna my
thing with patreon is when I support
people on patreon I don't really expect
my attitude is that I'm giving I'm
donating to support this person that's
how I see and I think I almost feels
here when I supply support just like
that I support people on
and I don't expect anything you know in
exchange people are expecting something
and they don't get it like I don't know
I mean it depends on the person it could
be a scam I don't know and then like I
guess the other way that you could scam
someone is making it sound like you're
struggling more is that a scam saying
implying that you're struggling more
then you know I mean exactly a scam I
guess it's less trite right yeah I think
like in our video we talked about very
risky I was going from a situation where
I had a paycheck no matter what we can
get we could've been getting three views
per video I can still take that check to
the bank I'm good
but I had to buy the channel back I had
to then or I didn't have to but I took
my staff which then all needed salaries
and lawyers fees then the new place then
getting gear if we weren't able to
already like get some of the gear and a
contract so it's a lot of initial cost
and also specifically with with
launching this new thing you don't know
what kind of backlash you're gonna get
there been people that tried to launch
things on patreon and it like [ __ ]
named their career and I think it's just
properly explaining what you're going to
do with it it was protecting properties
and shows already exist how rude you
know protecting properties and shows
that already exist and trying to build
out because once again like I want to
fill a hole that I see on the internet
that that bothers me it's why I do my
show it's why I want to expand and like
I even with the [ __ ] it's like can you
imagine if I actually was scamming
people how that's [ __ ] career suicide
on top of just being any more people
there'd be more people talking about not
getting [ __ ] I would eventually but
there might be like a screenshot of like
four to ten oh my goodness that randomly
pops up and we're gonna believe all of
them but like here's it I mean I'm
saying that that's not even a thing it's
like literally based off of one tweet
from a guy that's like but I don't think
he's scamming anybody I saw that tweet
by scarce actually I thought it was I
mean he's like I didn't get my stuff but
I think you you good any of the much
scares like contact us send a message
I'll also send you a mug
don't think you rat that tear but I'll
send you a mom I was saying to you when
we were on break and I'll say it here
too I think your idea of eventually
moving it to a different platform that's
it's probably a really good idea because
patron is just by nature associated with
just being a donation right and I think
that there that once again I think
they're trying to get past it but as
long as there are people that use in
that manner which hey no hate there are
a lot of small creators that yeah like
they don't need more [ __ ] on their plate
in addition to what they're already
providing I think but I think for me
personally just because everything that
I do and that connotation same thing I
said on the phone today to to jack conte
my plan is now has been expedited to get
off-site obviously that's not
specifically because of the connotation
but it definitely plays into it yeah I
think I think it would help like help
the work some of the criticism because
you make me not crowbar separation but I
think a lot of this just fueled by
bitterness that like you get I know I
never want to say that it's bitterness
right I mean it's it's it's Fitz there's
people that are that are bitter that
we're making money
no and I like somehow I just see that it
bothers people and it's what fuels their
criticism of you it's like there's
something of like I don't know what I
don't know what it is like if I'm not
walking around in like Gucci and [ __ ]
is flaunting my wealth all the time I'm
being dishonest about how much money I'm
making or something I mean I don't talk
about how much money we would make
because I just don't find it becoming
right I get that and some people just
like different [ __ ] like I I put my
money and like tech right like I'm not I
have like I think I got this shirt from
j.crew which is a nice quality shirt
which you should buy unless you guys
have a clothing brand yeah well we still
need yeah I'm not there yet is [ __ ]
insane bro this is coming drop - holy
[ __ ] in January it came out amazing says
happy like that down the sleeve it was
happy like that like someone who would
wear a sweater with a teddy bear on yeah
I don't know it's all sloppy I I mean if
anyone could look at our Channel and not
like assume that we're doing very well I
don't know I mean it's pretty obvious
right I mean we're not mm-hmm and I
guess the same would be true of any
large youtuber you have to assume
certain extent that they're they're
wealthy well it's dangerous though too
because there are people that don't have
the the kind of post schedules they have
kind of content where like we've been
very fortunate to have been on the site
for a long time and and also in addition
to our support work with specific
sponsors that totally back us it's so
like I hate when people assume every
creator has I cash it ton of money
because there's some people out there
that haven't monetized properly or
they're new or they don't have a good
release schedule and they're not making
that much they're going like check to
check yeah sure and so I think like
that's the thing like I'm doing if
you're getting over 10 million views a
month mm-hmm for the most part you're
probably it also demands a nice living
it also depends on region I have some
friends yes of course yeah it's like
Spanish focused audience yeah okay yeah
I think putting it also depends how long
ago even if you're getting the worst
monetization and you're getting ten
million views a month you're still
probably making like around at least
$10,000 a month yeah wait so if you're
American if you're getting ten million
views a month you're gonna probably be
making at least and you're American and
you have a mostly American English
speaking audience yes you probably gonna
be making at least $10,000 a month it
also depends on your D monetization
issues I've seen people are worse to
monetization issues than me I feel like
even then mmm even these days you have
to really be [ __ ] up to not monetize
it to that level I'm just trying to be
frank about like how money works on
YouTube yeah well I'm trying to also
keep it open in the sense of way cuz I
know guys that get triple my views but
on Adsense they get less because their
audience is an english-speaking so
they're they may be American but that's
an exception yeah sure but yeah
- the something I've been thinking about
yes off like the amount of criticism
that you can get when you're in it
you're at a point where everyone's it's
so easy to shoot up right to punch up
mmm when I when we were coming up on
YouTube we could talk [ __ ] say anything
about anyone and like you just you don't
feel you don't feel the sense of
responsibility you don't feel so much
the consequence of what you're saying
because you're just some guy and [ __ ]
you know like we could speed what suck
[ __ ] say anything about anyone but when
you're on top and you become the guy
that everyone has that attitude about
right it definitely affects you so my
question is housing
how important is headspace to what you
do what do you mean headspace like
mental where are you mentally like do
you have are you I found like how's your
how your mood affects like do you do you
focus on your mental health like I you
conquered the physical world in a sense
right I wouldn't start saying it at
least but at you do you find the
conquering the internal world of your
own mind is something that you ever
think about like is it part of your
daily routine recently i i i can in my
inside my head is a very horrible toxic
place i think like a lot of people that
once again it's not it's not like a pity
story what part of being here is being
criticized by everyone by for everything
that you do and so it can be a toxic
place i think a skill that I've worked
on pretty well is not not stopping for
every barking dog for to not say
everything that I feel like saying
because my words have really sharp teeth
sometimes it says slip out it's
something that I I try and think about
and work on despite my audience whenever
it comes out letting me know they love
that and I'm just like I hate that part
of myself I've recently over the past
week start trying to meditate five five
minutes a day and it is oddly put me in
a good place
I thought I thought it was kind of
[ __ ] but just taking a moment to
just like like say [ __ ] all things like
ideas are gonna go through your minds
just try it try the the try as well as
you can to to to not grab on to them
like just just be fine with not like
letting a thought pass once again in no
way an expert I'm still on my free trial
at headspace because like um did you
talk about your tweet cuz I wanted to
ask you about that
I haven't really well the one about Fame
yeah which I think probably connects to
it yeah I don't know if I'm putting you
on the spot no no no it's all fair game
yeah I just found like that's really
it's just been so weird like in the past
month or man the past year generally
I've just I've only become aware of it
in the past like month or maybe two
where my moods just been like steadily
decreasing to a more negative cynical
cold place and its really been affecting
my work too I find that my comedy and
the work we do is best when I have
levity in my heart I said corny as that
sounds right that's like the least
comedian thing I've ever heard I don't
know why that's good well that seems
healthy when I'm when I'm unhappy and
I'm anxious and I'm an awful mood I just
I am I can't create comedy mm like I
truly feel like the work we create is a
really reflection of how we're feeling
at the time and I think that's a big
part of why we haven't been posting h3
videos so much is because I just been in
such a negative headspace recently and I
just reflecting on like reflecting on
how I've changed since since we've come
to I don't know whatever you want to
call it like Fame for lack of a better
word run YouTube is just like I just
feel like it's made me a worse person
like a distance myself from people you
know I must trust full of people I found
that I'm just really stamped yeah I can
be a total looking back on past
relationships it's clear now that it
wasn't at the time that I was just
really an [ __ ] hmm really like
standoffish Andrew
and expecting too much of people and not
being more aware of how my actions are
affecting them you know I think I think
the first step is just acknowledging
that I mean that's incredibly important
like we're all human we have these
horrible things you're in a position
that a smaller percentage of people then
then have had that have like going
through it and I think just when you see
that [ __ ] thing just holding on to it
I personally find the people I hate the
most are full embodied representations
of my worst moments like my 10 like my
worst temporary moments so I think it's
fine I mean do you like is there is
there a specific thing recently and I
had nothing it's it's a lot of stuff
it's a lot of it's just a general
personality change I think and like
looking back at like what's like the
Golden Age of Age 3 was like a really
carefree happy time and which like there
was just really no bitterness or you
know there's no bitterness in me and it
really was like a blossoming creative
time and I think the more negative I
feel the more I hate myself the more
that I don't believe in my creativity
and my product and it's like this
vicious cycle of just closing in on
myself mm-hmm and anyway I agree there
like I've been feeling like there's
something wrong for a long time and I
think that was the first time I like
verbalized it and I really felt like by
just saying it that would be the
beginning of hopefully some kind of
journey of getting better how how has it
been since then it's been good I mean
like it's been tumultuous a little bit
and cuz it's it's hard to come to terms
with like not liking yourself you know I
mean but when you when you it know but
when you acknowledge that thing that you
don't like about yourself is it's very
easy I think to go like and that sucks
but are you then taking steps to modify
yourself your behavior yeah tell your
interactions yeah well I think it's a
[ __ ] process like I'm not and I say
that in the sense of I don't want you to
feel bad about this very normal human
thing like I want you to like going
through it's
it sucks yeah life is awesome and also
the [ __ ] worst
yeah I mean it's it's so frustrating to
have achieved everything you've ever
wanted and to be like miserable but I
guess so
achieved everything you ever wanted like
you have what you have now but like why
do you keep doing it I don't know that's
so you don't have an answer you don't
have like you don't have the answer to
like the question of why keep doing I
felt like completely stuck for a whole
year like I wasn't developing mentally
professionally my thoughts were
unoriginal I was obsessing about the
same stupid [ __ ] all the time
I felt like completely stuck and
previously I was always to pry to my
like my self-awareness and my
development and feeling like I was
growing and becoming more Chur and just
I felt like so [ __ ] stuck so I guess
like the process of becoming unstuck
it's very abstract I don't know if it
makes sense now it does I mean just in
life you're beaming yeah yeah yeah my
horn lights if it you're in life in my
mind and everything is is I mean it's
painful because I'm confronting like I
said things that I that I don't like
about myself it's important though to it
that's good I mean so having that
thought did that come purely from you or
are you lucky enough to have someone in
your inner circle that was willing to
call you on some [ __ ] cuz that's that's
if that's important I think a lot of
negativity was bubbling about us and I
think it was all a reflection of stuff
that we weren't we were putting out I
think a lot of it was exaggerated and it
made whenever you make yourself
vulnerable there's tons of people who
are quick to take advantage of that and
to use it against you right so it's hard
to make yourself vulnerable when you're
in the position that we're in because
you they make people there's people that
will make you regret that right right so
I think I was very hesitant to make
myself form but because I felt like
misrepresented and unfairly criticized
by a lot of people and I think there was
a certain point when all this negativity
kind of mounted and I realized maybe
they're not completely right what
they're saying because I'm so defensive
yeah like when someone criticizes me
I'm just like they're totally wrong I
and their [ __ ] I hate that person so
it's like maybe they're not totally
right but they're probably a little
right yeah right I mean that's the stuff
that hurts is when someone says some
[ __ ] that you thought like I this is on
a completely different level but I did a
video last week that was nothing but one
story about a youtuber and it was like
really well done in the research and
everything but I was like this isn't
what I'm [ __ ] doing why am i why am I
doing this I got I got like transacted
yeah I got like timewise I got trapped
and I was like well we could either post
really later this is the [ __ ] video
and like it wasn't like random people
come to my videos it was my guys and I
was like you know what you're all like
you're saying the [ __ ] things I agree
with that also makes it hurt most but
let me acknowledge and own it right and
and I think but that's like that's also
I think what makes it potentially
different than any other like mainstream
artist when when something happens with
mainstream artists it's like very
thought out ok I apologize for this for
offending we can have a conversation be
honest with an audience member and
hopefully that actually brings us closer
right because it's like okay we can be
critical of each other it has it doesn't
have to be like I'm just I just blindly
follow you cuz that's like obviously
every audience has that but I don't want
that that's too much right sure yeah
yeah I think that's true and I think in
a lot of ways there's I felt like a
distance between us and our audience
which sucks because I think the
closeness of us with our audience as
well it was made kind of what I felt we
were doing special yeah and so I'm
trying to get back to that in a genuine
way but let's let's let's move forward
into this like why do you guys do this
podcast now other than it's part of your
schedule I mean yeah what's the goal
yeah like is it just cuz it's like a fun
time to hang is it moving forward is it
just like right a lot of people in our
business they they try and grow just so
they get more [ __ ] that's a compared to
the other people [ __ ] is it is it
notoriety is it a specific kind of
impact right and I think that's like the
hopefully what we all try and kind of
end up hitting it doesn't have to be
doesn't take anything away
but like why do you do the podcast why
do you still put yourself out there
because there's got to be a reason like
if if we're in a headspace where we're
making ourselves at certain times right
because I've gone through [ __ ] peaks
and valleys like why are we do it like
if we don't have that that kind of North
Star of the answer I think then we just
have to try it we don't have to find it
before we keep moving forward but just
it should be part of the process like
what is it
well the podcast has been an anchor for
us throughout this shitty time for me
personally because we've been pretty
absent on our main channel and this is
like forced us to come out regularly
talk with our fans have this show this
experience and um for me it's really
been an anchor I mean I think it's been
hard to come out here and do the show
when I'm struggling it's gnarly but it's
also it's really healthy to force
yourself to have to work right okay so
but it keeps our it keeps us active at a
time when I was you know sleeping or
whatever you want to say so it sounds
like it's all right now at least it's
all about stability like emotional and
like doing something right yeah I think
so and and maybe even connection with
your audience that's it that's a big
part feeling connected especially which
is very but that's also I want to say
that's so dangerous for us to feel
especially because I've pushed people
away like my inner circle is very small
but pushing so many people away where
the primaries the primary source of who
we feel connected to is our audience I
feel like it should be part of the
equation but that's where that's where I
feel like I've had my darkest times
where it's like my audience essentially
controlled me which it's there's a
strong core there but there they can be
fluid right you can't control who finds
you who and what they say to you I don't
know I love talking about stuff like
that yeah open about stuff like that
because a lot people just keep that [ __ ]
inside and then they'd have that video
where they just [ __ ] break down like
mmm you know I think openness is
important and I think is important for
people to know that like I hate this
notion that like if you're successful
you can't complain right - well no one
wants to look up
the hill and see someone [ __ ]
problems right yes it's like because
like you just because you have a good
living doesn't mean that you can't have
problems feeling a lot it but you know
like also everyone's got problem I don't
know the whole thing is [ __ ] a man
once again it's not a Crimea rivers
things but you feel guilty for feeling
bad and then that makes everything worse
sorry there's there's something there's
something that's kind of also hilarious
about how [ __ ] horrible being human
is you know I was we just got this puppy
and he's so cute and carefree he's a
perfect angel he's he's without sin and
I think that creatures like this exist
why we as humans love these creatures is
because they exist for us like they
exist for us to like see that that to
live vicariously through them so
something can be pure this we have this
pure creature and even though pure like
our lives are complicated and messy at
the time so miserable this there's this
pure wonderful creature who's a angel
sentinels rat it and it's like the fact
that that can exist in some state is uh
it's it's it's comforting right it is
comforting to know like I I genuinely
love that yeah I mean something so
simple so pure
he doesn't have thoughts because if he
did he'd be [ __ ] I think that's that's
everyone getting higher drinking
everyone wants makes himself make
themselves a little more simple life
simple yeah for a second do you think
that fames changed you do you think that
it's changing for the better or the
worse long-term better initially
horrible I talked about it behind videos
in the past but I remember just like
there was this one moment that my wife
was she was then girlfriend cut me off
where I was I always like I was about to
be like alright no I actually said to
her I was like does he [ __ ] know who
I am
wasn't even Cuban mine nine years ago
[ __ ] it's also why I try and
be a little more lenient with some of
the newcomers when they initially come
up because you're going from regular
life to all of a sudden everyone says
you're [ __ ] awesome and all this
great shit's happening but then you only
get a little bit of runway then you can
you can quickly find out who has good
people around them to call them on their
[ __ ] which is why I asked if someone had
kind of mentioned something to you
or you can have horrible hanger-ons that
are just yes yes yes yes yes and some
some try and use it for themselves and
some are just content holding on but no
I think long-term
good I think that it's made me there
were there dark times and in the middle
but I have this this big goal of trying
to communicate and getting people
involved in a bigger dialogue right I
had to go through a time where I didn't
know why I was doing it like why am i
[ __ ] moving but I think in general
better purpose was that like the purpose
but also being in this position allows
you to see people from so many different
backgrounds like I have my very limited
experience you guys have your experience
and as storied as it might be it is
relatively limited when when you think
about the scope of the world so seeing
everybody and keep in mind only the
people that are sounding off and sharing
their story with me but that's that's
made me appreciate being more open
because not everyone has my same story
it's easy to talk about a topic when you
think that there is one
uh none deterred truth but that's not
that's just not at the world so I think
it's I feel like I've become better
because of it and I've it gave me my
purpose it gave me a connection to
people that's cool but there are dark
days people came up here there are dark
days I'm not like [ __ ] glowing
sunshine everything I talk about
everything good my life came from me
being a horrible place and and being
pissed off I want to talk to switch
gears a little bit here yeah about the
daddy of five saga I found that whole
thing a little bit fascinating for lack
of a better word dan give me a frickin
break please I found it really
fascinating exactly what I said
I'm a living meme with myself
you went super hard on those guys you
guys basically had a beef right no I
wouldn't call it a beef I I did detailed
reporting on a person that was doing
there was calls and responses right well
he was he was trying to convince his
audience that I was somehow the real bad
person in the situation which was weird
cuz I wasn't the person that was pushing
children or hitting children or having
other children slap the other kid as
part of a fun video where we're going to
monetize it and apparently law
enforcement agreed with me that it
wasn't okay right and now they had to
change their channel to family of five
because the other two that could answer
yeah with the if unless there's been a
dramatic change in the past two weeks
but yeah man that's I wouldn't call it
be it was just some guy trying to say
that what he was doing wasn't wrong yeah
and actually and it's not it's not okay
just for me to put it on Mike it was
both the pic both the parents they were
choosing to put put everything up and
the fact they're still on the internet
they still have an audience that has
seemingly just forgiven them or not even
forgiven them have been in their corner
the entire time it's disgusting their
defense of that channel do perplex me I
don't know who they are because there's
so what there's like a decent amount of
people watching like thirty fifty yeah I
mean I was and I'm like yeah they're
nowhere near where they were yeah but
well III like in that case like your
reporting I could say I don't know if
it's single handily but it resulted in
also their I do want to say cuz I didn't
do all the work myself there were a lot
of independent people including like
people like Nick Monroe that did a lot
of investigative work and so I don't
want I don't want there to be some idea
like it was just me on the phone I had
the large audience yeah but and I'm so
thankful for them because without them
most likely nothing would have happened
oh yeah I just want to say that so it's
not like I'm trying oh you and others
yes
word I mean directly responsible for
these kids being removed from the house
I think we're responsible was talking
about it I mean we made a video to it
was like a general yeah
online if they're like okay fine I mean
what I would say is responsible for her
or more people paying attention to this
thing we were responsible for more
people paying attention to yeah
obviously messed up situation and and
then luckily the people that are
supposed to do what they're supposed to
do in that situation did it right very
thanks very much to so many people that
made sure they downloaded the videos
before they private at everything making
sure that that everything that had been
openly it was it was there for so long
if it hadn't been for one video that
just happened to go viral right it would
have been the same situations kind of
well I guess the point that it's it's
kind of it's scary in a way that like
you can wield that much power to like
break up a family well it what it was
deserved or not just it was I mean I
need to see I got direct if you're if
you are putting something out on the
internet obviously I understand if
you're surprised if you have a small
account and something happens right like
those people that say something and all
the sudden goes viral but we're in a
position where enough people see it and
hopefully enough people move on
something to protect like in the
situation and once again it's all about
the way you say it like kids getting
take away kids being moved to safety
right kids being moved to hopefully more
okay situation where I'm sorry when
you're that young unless that kid went
to some [ __ ] crazy acting classes
like that's video in particular was the
slap video I think was the one the heck
one was the one was like that was like
well that's not rough yeah yeah that's
you monetize the video of children
hitting each other alright but yeah I
mean that's I mean that's a situation
that's still moving forward I just I
just learned today that someone's been
trying to to reach out and so because
there's something something I don't I
don't know the full detail so I don't
want to just like yes sure sure but yeah
no I'm I'm I am very happy that my show
can have an effect in the real world
especially when it's children in danger
yeah and what I perceive to be danger
yeah well ultimately and
worth noting as you did it was
ultimately the police who decided died
it was an unsafe situation for the
authorities got involved and what
happened happened right yeah but as you
touched on he's back under a new banner
day yeah oh five day they are back they
uh yeah I think they have like certain
stipulations as far as what they're able
to show in the videos I don't know I
have to buy like childhood it's part of
its I think it's part of their plea deal
I have to know the specifics I haven't
once again I haven't looked into it and
a little while I just became aware that
they were still going strong yeah what
do you think about these guys back on
YouTube I mean I think they're
discussing individuals the the court
system decided what they decided I think
that you know III and everyone else
involved have to be okay with that but
I'm if something happens I'm pretty sure
people are going to respond or contact
us yeah hopefully hopefully they're more
tame I mean for sure like you said if he
ever told the line it would come up
immediately
yeah I mean I'm sure I have to they have
to be paying attention to what they're
putting out now I imagine I don't know I
just anyone that does anything to
children I just want them do stuff that
I shouldn't say on a podcast that's out
to as many people as you guys hit yeah
that whole saga was was bananas man yeah
the whole story of it that's I got so I
remember there was one moment I got so
annoyed when I think it was Good Morning
America did a piece on them and it was
after like some of the worst footage had
come out and they like did a sit-down
interview and there was it was weird
right they day the family was on the
news yeah the family was on the news
they sent someone down there - I think
talk to them or talk about it and the
main takeaway like you could see
something weird with them but they
didn't show the worst footage most
likely because they're on morning
television and they kind of just like
played up what the family has been
saying of like the family says it's fake
anyway on to this lofty nothing piece I
was like this is a [ __ ] this once
again real situation real people and
most importantly children that do not
have control of their lives
it's that's funny see a puff piece right
for daddy of five well I wouldn't say
that it's like they were like giving
them a massage but you could they didn't
show the yeah it was like it was
something to fill time right there was
no it seemed like there was really no
care about the people involved you know
I remember when that video first floated
to our attention was several months
before the story blew up was the one of
him like tearing up his room yeah and
then being like Cody yeah whatever just
stop being a [ __ ] whatever it was
awful and me I remember watching with
you and be like how do I even like this
is just too awful yeah I can't how do i
what am I gonna respond Steve all when
we made a double reaction to it his
comment was so perfect he's like oh I
understand why this isn't funny we're
watching child abuse I was like that's
[ __ ] you've really just nailed it
down genuinely disgusted that video was
was great that was a perfect one to
watch with Steve oh yes he's like the
prank god right and be like this is not
a [ __ ] prayer I would like to I Steve
I would like to separate myself remember
being associated with this thing okay
right well that was a great conversation
thank you
ground not really me go meditate after
this one yeah yeah I'm saying once again
apparently I'm just given three sponsors
headspace app it's been great so far but
that's good that's because I've gotten
to the part I haven't gotten to the part
where have to start paying yet get me
addicted yeah I guess there's customary
question for all of our guests at the
end of our show
okay our fans will kill me if I don't
ask oh do you have any ghost stories
more paranormal experiences alien visits
well if this is a common question I feel
bad because your audience is going to
hate me because I hate when people share
ghost stories because I think it's just
[ __ ] well I have not I think that's
the thing what's interesting the but
it's surprising how many people do have
stories right he's like I remember one
one day I woke up and I looked to the
doorframe and I
saw my mother and I didn't have the
heart to be like or you guys just been
groggy and I'm [ __ ] pain medication
it's okay yeah but whatever makes you
happy well I think it's a great like
dichotomy is that right word my
overstepping my diction it's a great
contrast to say because I'm very I don't
believe in any of that stuff mm-hmm
and I'm constantly surprised by who has
them and to what scope we had jordan
peterson on here and he had this
elaborate and i was like i feel like a
complete idiot asking Jordan Peterson if
he has a ghost story and the best ghost
story and so I think I'm so never know
you know so sorry it's totally fine
that's life yeah that's I'm not saying
everybody that has a great story is
crazy yeah but I just don't have them
and I don't believe in it yeah yeah me
too and I think you're weak minded if
you experience false belief that I'm an
okay person yeah let's listen up all
right well thanks for joining us I
thought that was a great combo we
covered a lot of ground there yeah I
don't I was gonna make a fire joke oh
god oh god are you still alive nobody
died right I don't know I don't have
[ __ ] Google right in front of me you
guys guy how many people know I'm like
there's gonna be a fire outside I have
no [ __ ] idea I think so far nobody
died so it's safe to joke about this is
the role it's just their stuff in their
lives guys yeah that's fine it's just
stuff I don't think that's I stopped I
only referenced and fully explained it
would have been anyway thanks again
thank you
I'm gonna I'm gonna drink this water
that's not in the cup to fill the time
can you get a close-up of that mug here
damn right this mug will be on our
website next week yeah rep your name
grab your nish
oh let's end with the put on shredder
cam right there welljust will log out
softly with shredder camera and fade
with the podcast theme so with that I
say goodbye I love you appreciate you
we're actually working on an h3 video
this weekend will hopefully be out
tomorrow I'm very happy and excited
about it I leave you with shredder the
pure sinless angel he's here to remind
basically looking at the can't look at
this dog
he is pure of soul and honey lives to
love and to cuddle and to comfort he is
pure he is sinless he original sin does
not apply to this animal yeah everything
bad about him just comes out it's it's
what it's how we all want to exist but
it's okay because he's living for all us
sinners shredder is Jesus shredder is
Jesus he's living for all of us shredder
shredder he shreds for all of us look at
this monster give me a [ __ ] right on
cue here's the thing about babies not
everyone loves babies everyone loves
puppies I hope so I hope everyone loves
puppies come on I mean like not like
puppies though I think puppies elicits a
response and humans for whatever reason
that I don't think babies reach that
level of emotional like for Alex for me
and if it applies to me it applies to
everybody how's it gonna want to talk
about my bowing yes it's like every time
cats no I don't care about cats you hate
cats
I don't like them I'm talking about
that's a bold opinion all right get back
to shredder what matters all right guys
I love you thank you for watching
everybody with the peace and the comfort
that this dog exists in right now and I
hope that you all find a piece of that
comfort in this have a great weekend
have a great weekend think spend your
time with us love you bye
[Music]